[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Сіверщина,
Хутір Обирок]
На Обирку так тихо,
що чутно, як падає сніг.
Сюди звукорежисери приїжджають,
щоб записувати звук, як падає сніг.
Цей шурхіт снігу, що падає.
[Леонід Кантер
Режисер, мандрівник, співзасновник Хутора]
Тому перш за все за тишею, але водночас
тут дуже цікаві люди збираються.
Ті фільтри, які ми поставили:
без алкоголю, тютюну та наркотиків
в наметах,
те, що всі тут працюють,
щось роблять, —
це для багатьох неприйнятні речі,
то вони і не їдуть.
У такий спосіб ми не маємо тут тих,
хто ходить під себе, кидає сміття
всюди, де попало, п'є алкоголь...
Тому тут дуже приємна атмосфера,
дуже класні люди довкола.
За ними також сюди
приїжджають інші люди,
щоб поспілкуватися, познайомитися
з новими прикольними особистостями.
Ми сюди приїхали у 2007 році.
У листопаді.
Почали обживатися.
А почали з того, що спалили всі паркани,
що тут були, а в нас не було дров.
— Ого, ти сам приїхав?
— Так.
Чекай, у тебе щось на зубах.
Все, зняв.
Сам приїхав? Я бачу, вона сама їде...
Це Прохори.
Це Каціри.
А це Королі.
Тобто це три хуторки,
які являють колишнє село Обирок,
що налічувало 100 хат.
Тепер лишилося лише 32 - 33.
Ми зайшли у цей двір,
а вже була зима, все снігом запорошено.
Вийшли на цей пагорб, з того боку...
Подивилися: «Ого!»
І вирішили, що купуємо [будинок].
Навіть не заходили всередину до хати.
Загалом, там нічого і не було.
Там усе покрали, особливо залізне.
Печі також вириті.
Що? Куди? Далі?
Добре, поїдемо ще вниз...
Одразу, коли ми заселилися,
то збудували сауну, бо неможливо було жити.
Ні! Брешу! Ми зремонтували піч.
Найперше, що ми зробили ,—
зремонтували піч.
І спали коло неї, притулившись.
Потім почистили криницю,
журавля і почали брати воду.
У нас з'явилася вода.
Почали будувати баню
і за півтора місяці збудували її.
Так наше життя стало схожим до того,
як у місті люди живуть:
ми почали митися гарячою водою. Знову!
Насправді тут було кайфово від початку,
тому що ти як в таке місце потрапляєш —
це ж пригода.
І от 10 років ця пригода вже триває.
За цей час багато чого змінилося.
Уже побут ми налагодили,
а тепер розважаємося і
створюємо різноманітні арт-об'єкти.
Отакий дядько, бачиш?
Це сад занепаду імперії.
Ви можете спостерігати,
як природа знищує все,
що здається незнищенним.
Ми хочемо, щоб тут була
трохи моторошна атмосфера.
Бачите, воно все поступово заростає лісом.
Буде лісочок і такі хатинки стоятимуть.
Багато хто з іноземців були в Борисполі і на Обирку.
Я щасливий від цього,
адже мені особисто не соромно,
якщо вони так сприйматимуть Україну.
Іноді мені соромно, коли виходить інакше.
Тут їм дуже подобається,
куди не зайдуть — всюди до них привітні.
Усі допоможуть,
більшість розуміє іноземні мови.
Хто приїжджає,
той почувається, наче вдома.
Ми почули ще одну розповідь про те,
що ми вже створили мережу мистецьких хуторів.
Вона лише починає розвиватися,
але вже ми маємо п'ять таких мереж.
Це «Хата Сонця».
Ця хата 1919 року.
Система, за якою вона побудована,
називається «з перекатом».
Що це таке?
Оця система — це перекат.
Відбувається топка:
ось тут грубка.
А потім... Проходьте сюди.
Оце все — димохід,
тобто дим іде по стіні
і виходить нагору.
Так нагрівається вся стіна.
Це дуже зручна система,
адже потрібно лише протопити,
закрити піч і вся стіна тепла.
Всередині хати є тепла стіна.
Вистачить одну-дві закладки дров
і в хаті буде дуже тепло, навіть взимку.
Тут буде дитячий майданчик.
Зараз ми проводимо підготовчі роботи.
Плануємо зробити пісочницю, лавки...
До кінця літа заплановано добудувати його.
Лівіше буде африканський ярмарок,
ближче до клуба.
Пізніше
після фестивалю на його місці
будуть проводитися майстер-класи.
Це наш суспільний простір.
За його виглядом
можна оцінювати населений пункт
чи громаду.
Наприклад, там є вбиральня суспільного простору.
Ось і клуб.
Ми у такій прибудові,
яка була в поганому стані.
Її підняли і розширили.
Зараз сюди вже не падає дощ.
Проте є ще над чим працювати в цьому приміщенні.
У перспективі тут можна буде роздягатися.
Поставили двері,
провели світло, збудували піч.
Цього року ми наважилися
відшліфувати підлогу
і залатати її.
Декілька днів тому,
силами активістів...
Я навіть не знав, що вони це зробили.
[сміється]
Силами активістів з Чернігівщини, які приїхали
допомогти, ще й покрили підлогу лаком.
Ти підіймаєш прапор
і говориш, що займаєшся певною діяльністю.
Довкола цього прапору об'єднуються люди.
Дехто, хто приїжджав сюди,
говорив, що хоче лишитися.
Щоразу, коли людина таке казала...
Таких випадків було близько тисячі.
Ми не проти.
Зрозуміло, що ти хочеш
взяти від цього місця —
тут дуже гарно і хороші люди.
Але головне, що ти хочеш дати цьому місцю.
Варто подумати про це.
Коли люди почали задумуватися,
це ще більше підштовхувало їх
до переїзду сюди.
Я, коли приїхав, нікого не знав.
Купив хату і навіть не знав, чи хтось тут живе.
Шукав воду, у мене її не було,
щоб розквасити глину.
Зайшов до сусіда,
вони сидять за столом — випивають.
І каже сусід: «О, а це що таке?».
Навіть не «хто», а «що»...
Я відповів: «Добрий день, я ваш сусід»...
«Хотів би взяти води».
Він погодився, зав'язалася розмова.
Виявилось, що це він забрав мої речі:
совки, віники, ганчірки і все інше.
Каже: «Та я думав, що тут поселились якісь роми,
от тобі твої речі повертаю назад».
Це був приємний жест від нього.
Ми набрали води і пішли додому.
Вже підійшли до будинку,
коли нас наздоганяють пару автівок,
з них вийшли чоловіки.
[емоційно] «Оце ти приїхав, чувак,
ти тут житимеш! Привіт!»
[з захватом] Такі здивовані були!
І потім почалося.
Спочатку вони думали, що я незрозуміло хто:
втік, сховався від кримінальної справи.
І тут вони помітили, що тут постійно
телебачення, якийсь рух...
Почали захоплюватись цим.
Відбулась певна «легалізація безумства».
Якщо сказали по телебаченню,
чи написали в газетах,
що це правильні речі —
значить це правильно.
Якщо це добре, значить це добре.
Ось так, за підтримки медіа, все почалося.
Намагаємось створити заказник.
З приводу цього триває дуже велика епопея.
Насправді, у нас були дуже гарні стосунки
з місцевими, доки це все не почалося.
Тепер добрі взаємини існують лише на хуторі.
Проте довкола нас всі люто ненавидять.
Через що?
А все через те, що ми намагаємось
зупинити вирубку лісу.
У цьому регіоні ті, кому треба було, — поїхали.
Лишилися ті, хто не мав можливості поїхати,
та ті, кого все влаштовує.
Влаштовує, тому що вони були замішані у схемах.
Решта, вони якось причетні.
Кум, сват, брат...
Дехто просто допомагає
або просто пиляє ліс за сто гривень.
Вони бояться, що втратять шматок хліба.
Насправді, шматок хліба втратять лише ті,
хто реально на цьому «рубає капусту».
А ті, що по сто гривень мають...
Гірше їм від цього не стане.
Але вони цього не розуміють.
Поки що їм байдуже.
Ми декларували анархію,
що в нас немає жодної структури,
все робиться саме собою.
Згодом, коли стало приїжджати більше людей
ми зрозуміли, що треба якось домовлятися.
Тому створили хутірську раду.
Вона існує теж онлайн,
тому що ми частіше зустрічаємось онлайн.
Також є зустрічі,
які допомагають нам
вирішувати якісь поточні питання.
Обговорюємо, чого ми хочемо і що робимо.
Я сподіваюся, що хутірська рада
рухатиме нас уперед.
Звісно, цього треба прагнути.
Особисто я планую наступну подорож.
Також цього року хочу піти на пенсію...
Вже десять років тут мешкаю...
А ви напевно знаєте, що ті,
хто після другої каденції балотується втретє, —
вони всі несповна розуму.
Я вирішив випередити цю ситуацію,
тому що вже відчуваю,
що дуже занурився у цей проєкт.
Не можу припустити, що тут щось розвиватиметься не так, як я собі це уявляю.
Тому треба якнайшвидше позбутись таких думок.
Іти на пенсію, сидіти і рибалити.
Ловити рибку,
прогулюватися лісом.
Я планую поїхати в Африку.
Сподіваюся, надовго,
щонайменше на два роки або більше.
Хочу побачити всю Африку.
Всюди побувати,
пізнати різні культури, людей і місця.
Хотів би зустріти схожий хутір
і там залишитись на якийсь час.
Якщо там щось подібне існує.
[лунають ритмічні звуки барабана]
Будь ласка, підходьте всі сюди.
Зараз ми будемо спілкуватися.
У чому цей процес полягає?
Завтра починається фестиваль.
а ми не знаємо імена одне одного,
не кажучи вже про те, хто чим займається.
Нумо кожен представиться.
Скаже кілька слів про себе.
Хто, що, чому сюди приїхав/-ла?
Чого прагне в житті?
Потім розповідач має передати
«магічну паличку» по колу.
У кого магічна паличка — той говорить.
А в кого немає палички, той не говорить.
— Мовчить.
[тріщить багаття]
[плаче дитина]
Я пропоную почати з Діани,
щоб ти могла втекти завчасно.
— Я краще в кінці [говоритиму.]
— Окей.
— Ой, ні, гаразд, давайте я.
— Диви, бачиш, як я придумав. [сміються]
[Діана Карпенко
Співзасновниця Хутора Обирок]
Мене звати Діана, я тут мешкаю.
Фестиваль, який відбудеться завтра...
[тріщить багаття]
Ідемо, щось розкажу тобі,
поки мама договорить.
Іди до мене...
Обережно, бо ми зруйнуємо гірлянду.
Хто це там, дивись, хто це?
— Дядько!
— Дядько? Що він робить?
[пошепки]
Що це він робить?
— Дядько!
— [пошепки] Так, а що він тримає у руках?
[дитина нерозбірливо говорить]
— Що?
— Фотік у нього, бачиш?
— Фотік.
— А там зверху лампа.
— Лампа...
— Так, він знімає тебе для фільму.
— Для фільму...
— Так, для фільму.
Ти потім будеш там говорити.
— Можеш щось сказати до камери. Хочеш?
— Так.
— Ті...
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Марія Теребус]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Sasha Boole, Endless Melancholy]
[Субтитрувальник
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]